those generous
yeah his shoulders below the wrist man
you see I do don't leave it that like
his shoulder to do now
nice when he grabs we don't want to
contest that point okay you completely
go around it so your body maneuver let's
say pretend my hand is there right you
have to trace places with that grip
plumbing issue okay you one side the
front side is going to disappear and
become the back side front side back
side
let's go back to eat yogurt all right
and you see live in this corner here
this just kind of front back corner but
when I start to spiral I'm starting to
get behind her and I become the center
of the spiral do you guys see that as
opposed to if I'm out here and I start
to spiral I'm guaranteeing that I'm not
going to be the center of that spiral
and I have to pull her back to that same
condition I was in so I'm going to step
into this front back corner and as I
spiral I'm becoming the center you guys
all see that okay so this is same thing
here I can't do it out here she's behind
me we're kind of rotating around each
other I have to be that Center back here
so that she goes around
get to that back corner
although the technique has a brutal
geometry your inside has to be easy so
you can't you can't come here and do
this all hesitantly that's not any any
spirit so we're not architects you're
going external but you have to have all
of you self in the technique